[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app what's up
it's me and you're listening to
congratulations the podcast episode 126
now before we start let's tell you where
I'm gonna be this week you can pick up
some tickets some of it's sold out but
some of it is not so I'm going to be in
Hoover Alabama on June 26th for two
shows Memphis Tennessee June 27th
Chattanooga Tennessee why'd you name it
that way
June 28th and Knoxville Tennessee June
29th I now look we still sit down and do
the podcast am i stuffed up yes is my
ear clogged yes was it clogged earlier
in the week no and then when I took a
flight back to LA did it clog when I got
in the air yes did I undo it by
swallowing an opening on my mouth
over and over again in the air yes it
was a front in the air after that yes
and then when I land did it get clogged
yes and then after I landed did I try to
do the swallowing and open their mouth
to clear it up again yes they're working
know so don't yes but this is a make med
yes would I have rather it worked when I
landed then when I was on the plane of
course but is that how life works out no
it's gotta be the most annoying way
possible and that's fine because you
know what honestly I still barking up
the Brinks truck my babies that's why
okay
now I'm live on my app and there are
commenting right now and you can
download my app just type in Chris
D'Elia whenever the [__] you want on the
App Store and Andrew Cavalier cool last
name said comments right now on my live
feed I'm gonna see you in Hoover on
Wednesday well there you go buddy I'll
see you there
and then another guy named Aaron Adams
just wrote poop so that's cool hey so
all good grow up it's all good I really
really can't I I have no I there's I
mean in if there's anyone in the world
that can't tell somebody else to grow up
it's me okay because I mean I've made so
many fart noises on this [__] podcast
and also talked about spots isn't coming
so much so but it's episode 126 and you
know it's cool it's very cool I just had
a meeting with Joshua the borough
manager and it was good and the whole
[__] you know he's he's my manager as
I look isn't luck he's him and it was
all good we had a good meeting so we're
trying to develop some TV shows and it's
all good
I don't know you know [__] this week
was good I was at a wedding and also I
was at a lake so you figured out my
babies dude does D'Elia go to the
[__] lake you're goddamn right he
does I go to the lake i chilled I was in
a kayak you saw my Instagram I was doing
it like this
I was rowing I was going I was roaming
like this and I look [__] good dude I
looked at beef he meant my shoulders
were [__] you know I was the
president saying tip over but it's all
good you can't be in a kayak without
looking like you're a [__] paraplegic
by the way it's just impossible because
your legs are so [__] wedged in there
now was I sick kinda am I on the mend
yeah somebody comments on my app bodies
of water man as good as it gets
okay alright man sure the name's Adam
bone saw ahead
change it so and then also I was in
Philly for a wedding and that was where
Michael anoche fell down on the concrete
because he was drunk and then farted and
it was hilarious dude he has so much
[__] dude he is a funny drunk dude he
was so drunk where he was he got he was
so drunk where he was like doing the
thing with his fingers where he was just
like the people kind of become like Ray
Charles when they get drunk you know
like they're like like they're like a
little bit autistic just like touching
each each thumb to their fingers like
this over and over again but like dude
it was so he was so drunk and he would
you today mm aah it's um a mint hey man
chill
hey you know what it's Joe that's what
he kept saying and like hey man nobody's
not chillin nobody's not chill except
you ha ha and I kept pulling his [__]
I'll be about posting later but I kept
he would sit down and I kept pulling on
one of his arm down to the ground and he
would just fall down to the ground
hey hey come on man stop and then he
would just go to sit down again and I
would just pull his [__] arm anyway a
man he just fall on the ground but dude
it's so funny to [__] with your drunk
friends and he fell so hard dude
I started the code of my eye because I
want to throw something away of course I
wasn't looking and then I the core my
eye I saw like it seemed like when you
catch someone falling out of the corner
of your eye and it's nighttime I caught
like off the peripheral it felt like you
know when Dracula says ok bye-bye
and he goes in turns into a bat that's
what it felt that's what it felt like I
saw at the corner of my eye like a guy
just wisping will [__] bat and up and
fly away but instead it was my friend
who was so drunk and fell on the [__]
mist his step just straight up missed
his step in his stupid nice shoes
because you got to wear nice shoes his
wedding and [__] fell down dude and
he was the best part too was he was
eating a [__] he was eating a like me
and my girl we were at [__] 7-eleven
with him and we were eating a he had to
get tylenol and he
got a [__] brownie with a bunch of
[__] M&Ms in it and he was eating
like a [__] [__] and he was eating
that and then [__] fell and when he
fell the brownie fell on the ground and
his face literally was saved hitting the
concrete cuz he hit the [__] brownie
dude his face hit the brownie and he was
laughing it and he was he fell down his
ass was in the air his ass was in the
air like he was doing like the [__]
the worm
you know how in the 80s they used to do
the breakdance and [__] but then he got
stopped it was like the color wheel was
over his [__] ass while he was doing
the worm it was like his fruit his
screen got froze right in the middle of
him doing the worm the breakdancing worm
and dude we were dying and I thought he
turned into a bat and I looked over and
he was falling on the ground with Devon
honey had he still [__] put the last
piece of chocolate in his mouth while he
was laughing and dude I started
recording it you got to go my Instagram
I started recording it and as soon as I
started recording it he was laughing and
he goes oh and I swear to God it goes
and he farted bro bro he fell and he
farted
dude he's 35 or 36 and he fell and he
farted you only fall and you fart at
this you go fall you could fart but
falling and farting bro you're either 8
or 80 you're not 35 falling in farting
because he was laughing too hard he was
laughing too hard on the ground and he
couldn't let he couldn't like let he
couldn't close his sphincter you know
cuz he was laughing so hard and his ass
was arched up like he was trying to get
[__] like he was card to be and he
[__] couldn't stop laughing he's like
ha ha ha this is the you need to chill
you need to chill and just
[Music]
sigh anyway I can't tell anyone to grow
up let's see if I could find the the
Instagram here I'm gonna go to my
Instagram page bro yeah got it right
here here we go do you hear that fart
bro how happy am I by the way I sound
like [__] Bert Kreischer it was one
of those is one of those bro
Danny Vick when I was in in New Jersey
used to do fart noises with just his
lips which I thought was a [__] [__]
move he would just blow and I'd be like
bro it's you got to put your teeth over
your [__] bottom lip when you do fart
noises right and then he Vic's like nah
bro and he would just go pee and one
time Danny Vick had a [__] tank top
on a green tank top and I said bro and I
wanted to see if Danny Vick had [__]
armpit hair yet and I said bro keep make
a muscle let me see how big your muscles
are and he goes like this and he makes a
muscle and I said I'll cool and he said
I know why you made me do that I said
why he said you want to see if I had an
arm here yeah armpit hair yet and I said
no he caught me though but Danny Vick
used to make the [__] thing to go
with his lips that's the [__] he was
predicting the future bro
this is the mind night he was the
minority minority reporter farts he knew
that today that [__] this weekend
Michael anoche was gonna fall in just
fart with the lip [__] tell me that's
not two lips together and not a [__]
buck teeth over the [__] bottom lip
fart
bro how did it get so [__] loud in
this phone I thought for sure it
wouldn't pick up and what bro and why
did he dress like [__] queer ID oh my
god dude he set it up he [__] I it's
I showed up to the wedding I had a
long-sleeve [__] nice shirt and a
blazer ish type jacket and [__] dark
dark jeans he could barely two other
jeans and then [__] Gucci slipper
shit's you know what I mean not slippers
but you know what I mean and he and he
showed up in a suit and he was trying to
clown me for not wearing a [__] suit
and this dude looked like [__] swear
to God like queer I dressed him up and
then was like well that was the best we
could do and then he got so drunk and
fell on the streets of Philadelphia and
[__] farted bro and oh and it was so
annoying too cuz he he this guy saw us
oh it was so no this guy's so annoying
and this what you know they're talking
about he's [__] he was like forty five
to fifty and there was a guy there was
and and he was so he Sue's mic fell and
farty he said the guy was walked by he
says oh I blew his knee out and I was
like what he blew his knee out I was
like nah he's gonna be fine
no no no I saw the whole thing go down
he blew his knee out and I was like I
didn't buy it blow his knee out and he
was like oh yeah I did I saw it and I
was like all right man you ruined in the
fun dude if your friend falls in farts I
don't [__] get all up in your face
and be like hey is what happened is what
happened is what happens where happen
dude let me laugh at my friend catch the
fart on video cuz he [__] fell and
farted on the streets of Philadelphia
bro do you understand how funny that is
bro it's like this [__]
[Music]
this is Mike's theme song
that's it right there
[Music]
for the dog barking in the video right
there
[Music]
so disrespectful to Bruce Springsteen's
but that's what my kid
I get to avoid up dude he fell in the
streets of Philadelphia and farted
looking like queer I did dress like
[__] Jimmy neutrons alcoholic dad
just farting dude bro you dressed like a
[__] hairdresser and just [__]
down for the count
fool Oh for [__] sake dude he still
does the faux hawk [__] you know oh [__]
that's so goddamn funny 2019 with a faux
hawk falling down in a suit [__]
farting on the streets of Philadelphia
dude what's better than that spud
doesn't coming dude well have so much
video - I'm probably in a post-arrest of
that got a full I got post the rest of
it oh man there's so much video I kept
pulling his arm down I gotta post all
those goddamn it's so funny to dress so
nice and then get so [__] up and then
he kept telling the DJ he's like come on
the DJ will play a song it's so annoying
when people like try to tell the DJ what
to do it was so annoying that he and he
was like come on spoof it up he kept
saying spoof it up dude I was like do
you mean what do you mean spruce it up
what are you talking about you don't
spoof is and he kept saying spoof bro
come on
[Laughter]
spoof it up dude a [__] love friends
man I love friends and then he [__]
straight-up was like one time he was we
were video recording and he goes like
this
hey don't record me there's animals
don't record me there's animals do drunk
people are amazing dude what else did he
do
huh [__] man I was so annoying - cuz
during the wedding whatever you know how
people like will be like during the
wedding like people just when people are
giving speeches during the wedding
somebody'll be like yeah and you know
she's gonna be a doctor soon about the
the bride and everyone will be like yeah
I would go I would go like that I would
do this I would go dude and then I was
like she said I don't want to ruin the
wedding video but every now and then
sparingly I would go and nobody even
caught that it was weird because they
were just everyone was doing that ah
[__] man
spoof it up Danny Vic I don't know how
Danny Vic knew my dad maybe my eyes told
a story
maybe that's why maybe Danny Vic caught
me while my eyes were telling a story
looking down to his armpit hair got to
be better with my [__] move I got to
be better I would have been dead in in
that [__] book 1984 I'm in the middle
of reading a book 1984 put your drawer
well and that's the thing you can't even
have face crime that's a thing think
about that [__] dude I think it by the
way I agree with a lot of [__] going on
in the book 1984 I know people are like
all this totally total arey I can never
say the word took total totalit I can't
ever [__] say the word totalitarian
okay there so and people like no we
can't have that [__] that dude that's
that's the [__] face crime is a real
thing you got to have face crime
seriously if they'll
put you in jail if Big Brother says some
[__] over the telescreens and then you
go like this but that's it that's your
ass dude face crime
you got a cheer you gotta be like yeah
that's what you got to do in my world
that's how it is I'm not gonna kill
anybody and I'm not gonna go you know in
the log cabin it's not this is not you
can do what you want it's about [__]
and sucking you know what I mean but you
can't but you can't do face crime dude
if I'm talking in the log cabin and
somebody goes like this the [__] you're
out dude
go take it take a [__] hike take a
[__] straight up hike you can't do
face crime at the log cabin that's
that's that's that's an offense if I say
some [__] like you know what guys I saw
some vests earlier we're not gonna have
vests okay there's gonna be no vests in
you and you say oh yeah what the [__]
I go like this get out and that's you
and then you gotta walk across the
[__]
are they parted 42
there's a little fart afterwards you
can't really hear it but he went boom I
said oh you farted any good oh it's so
funny to like when when it's so funny to
think about like earlier like when the
guy sold him the suit you know like he
did not think like oh he's gonna [__]
fart in this suit but he did that's
amazing I love that kind of [__] um but
yeah you can't do face creme brulée
agree with so much of the [__] in the
1984 book I agree with it man
thoughtcrime face crime it's real
because you can't you can't if the guys
how much how many times in your life
have you wanted to knock somebody out
that guy that's gone like this how many
times how many times you said something
and somebody goes like one time I said
something that was 19 I was doing a
movie I forget the name in the movie it
was a fate worse than death
batgirls with Valley High's what it's
called you can get it on some [__]
thing I don't know it was 19 and I was
in the hotel room with a bunch of actors
and [__] and there was somebody on uh
like it was like a show like Jerry
Springer and they were dressed so funky
and I was like damn Louie that that's
crazy how they're dressed and some guy
goes one of the actors who's actually
kind of famous right now I'm not gonna
blow up his spot but this guy was a
[__] dick to me he goes he says bro
you ever been in New York like and I oh
of course I wanted to knock him out and
I go like this my man I live in LA you
know don't come at me with your stupid
New York [__] by the way yeah I've been
in New York I'm from New Jersey my dad
used to work in New York don't [__]
come at me with that face crime [__]
don't come at me when I'm like whoa look
at guys crazy
and then this guy comes up to me and
he's like this you ever been in New York
blue that blue that face crime
don't face crime eat in a [__] hotel
room in Vancouver British Columbia dude
you're gonna do face crime to me in
Canada talking about New York I'm from
LA dude [__] ass get out of here so
alright actor he's good actor you know
but I don't give a [__] dude because you
did face crime and if you do face crime
you're out anyway my point is I would
have lost in 1984 I would have got
[__] studded up the whole time I
would have got stupid I would have got
studded up every day cuz there's no way
I can hold my face crying I can't
thoughtcrime no way I'm thinking that
everyone's a [__] idiot I mean are
you [__] kidding me no way a girl
passed me a note that says she loved me
I won my heart would have beat it and I
would have been like oh my god stead of
that studded in jail for years
vaporized anyway dude face crimes a real
thing and we got to [__] get in
control of it it's it's it's like that
kind of thing is what this that kind of
thought is what this podcast is largely
against that kind of like bro you ever
been in New York that thought is what
this part that kernel of what that guy
is is what this this podcast is against
the guy who's always trying to see more
interesting than the next guy no because
you've been in New York you're somebody
bro get the [__] out of here it's like
the whole [__] it's like it's like
it's like the thing it's like the dad
bod thing it's like the pizza thing oh
I'm so interesting how much I like pizza
and I'm so skinny
go [__] yourself do it you're not
interesting get a personality don't eat
pizza get a person don't buy a pizza get
a personality get a personality with
some [__] toppings on it dude
get a meatlovers personality okay get a
Papa
John's personality because you're not
[__] interesting just because you
ordered a pizza and pose near it now
that's the kind of [__] that we're
talking about my babies this dad bought
[__] [__] take a take a [__] lunch
take a [__] hike bring your lunch
dude dad bought your not interesting
because you say I prefer a dad bog over
a six-pack
I get the sentiment I get what you're
saying you don't like guys that take
themselves too seriously and you don't
like a guy who's too into himself but
that doesn't mean you want a fat guy
face crime that doesn't mean that and if
you say that you're not interesting
because you think you are and the least
interesting people are the people who
think they're interesting oh dude me I'm
quirky I like a guy with love handles no
you don't take any guy you take your
boyfriend you'd like it if you [__]
trimmed up a little bit period you don't
know but I like his dad but no what
you're saying is you like his
personality we get that but also hey bud
tighten it up go ahead make excuses make
excuses for everybody that's fine we're
all gonna be [__] fat pieces of [__]
that's it
I can tell well beyond your [__] man
and and you should be able to - that's
the sentiment that this podcast is all
against and that's why this is a cult
and we are fighting against that [__]
[__] dadbod there are people who
literally think no I actually really do
prefer a dad bod and said no you don't
dude no you don't and people are like oh
well ok if Chris D'Elia says ok straight
white males it could be more like
straight white male says dad bods are
out ok fine dude go ahead go ahead
alright fine but that's not the truth
lie to yourself
also and then the article where they
were like hey dad bods are in it's like
it should Leonardo DiCaprio and [__]
Chris Pratt from seven years ago but you
mean guys with money and fame are in
show a real dad bad guy
so some guy you saw at the [__] shop
right earlier getting a bunch of ham and
some rolls show that guy
oh you don't cuz who is he a fat guy a
fat and it's fine to be fat and it's
fine to love who you are you should I'm
comfortable in my own body great cool be
comfortable be fat comfortable but don't
act like you're more attracted to a dad
bod than you are with a guy who's got a
[__] you know who's trimming it up
I'm not talking about the guy who's
[__] obnoxiously large and muscle
why's that guy's annoying his [__] to or
annoying his [__] rather not to because
nobody's annoying but him uh listen if
you're like me you're always paying
attention to your bank account balance
now I am always a paying attention
paying attention to my bank account
balance because I got to make sure no
dance at the moment you see you're going
to be overdrawn it's too late now I
forgot no dents that rarely happens but
some people have dents you end up
spending thirty-seven dollars on a cup
of coffee thanks to the bank fees hey
thanks a lot bank fees introducing the
Dave app putting an end to overdraft
fees for good no Dave is the number one
budgeting app in America because it
saves you from overdraft fee's tells you
about upcoming bills and can advance you
$75 from your next paycheck with no
credit check and no interest get the
Dave app and just for just one dollar
per month that's 12 dollars a year which
is way less than an overdraft fee and
you'll never have to pay one again as
you'll be like oh how much does this
paid just cause this is meant to remind
me order that's gotta pay that's gotta
at least cost $75,000 No one dollar per
month Dave will help you budget for
upcoming expenses text you if you're
spending too much and it's great
Mark Cuban is an investor in Dave
because he got crushed by overdraft
fee's in his 20s
now he's got no dents but he's trying to
help you out here so go to Dave com /
Congrats it really helps the show if you
let them know you heard them here then
download Dave and never pay another
overdraft fee again it's immediate
savings go now
Dave dot-com / Congrats spelled just
like it sounds da ve Dave com / Congrats
quip I'd like to keep my teeth clean but
I don't really know how to do it you
know it's time for spring cleaning Crips
got an easy way to start and quit helps
you keep your teeth clean and it helps
you know how to do it too brushing
habits just 2 minutes twice a day can
help pave the way to a healthier mouth
and mind and now the whole family can
get refreshed with quip the new kids
quip has the same two minute timer which
is what helps me and guiding pulses
which is what helps me to are as our
original version with no childish
gimmicks so that both if you have two
kids they both can or if your three kids
they all can or even more you all can
brush just like a grown-up like their
dad or mom which is cute and you want to
be cute right so it's got sensitive
sonic vibrations a built-in two timer
it's got built-in two timer pulses a
multi-use cover that you can stick it up
it works as a stand and you're gonna
stick it on your mirror which is very
cool brush heads are automatically
delivered every three months for just $5
a friendly reminder when it's time for a
refresh and to stay committed to your
oral health clip is great for keeping my
teeth dentist clean on the road and
that's why I love quip and why 1 million
happy healthy mouths do to quit starts
at just $25 and if you go to get clip
comm / Congrats right now you'll get
your first refill pack for free with
equip electric toothbrush that's your
first refill pack free at GE tqu IP comm
/ congrats you know is what it is one
fire came in with the [__] let's
break now and do another adlet later
because we got the [__] short of [__]
remember when I got mad at him because
of the shortest [__] one was coupled
with the two not coupled with the three
he came through one fire
I got more ads later but I got the short
of [__] one coupled with the two that's
great um yeah man we get it be
comfortable with your body sure for sure
but also it's better to be trim it's
better to be healthy it's better to be
moving it's better be active dude you
know I was at the Benjamin Franklin
Museum in Philly that dude was not
active he although he lived to be like
84 and he was not active and he was
[__] in so much pain for the later
part of his life and he had gout because
he never [__] moved around I'd like
to eat cheese or whatever the [__] Jesus
so good dude I could never be vegan cuz
of cheese there's no way put cheese in
my casket when I died I love cheese
don't really put it on my casket was my
bad not that I would be spelling it but
just in case you could smell when you
die don't put cheese on my casket um but
Benjamin Franklin was he invented so
many [__] things that was insane how
are you remember it's remember when like
inventor was a job I mean I know it
still kind of is you can still invent
stuff like Elon Musk but he's like that
only event like inventor what was like I
gotta keep telling it like in the in the
1700 you could be like yeah I gotta come
up with him a new thing because I'm an
inventor cuz we only got like 17 things
so far now everything's kind of been
invented and you gotta like really be
really [__] smart to be an inventor
but back then you could have been a
[__] you could have been like Michael
anoche and Benetton for government and
inventor like yeah you know this helps
when you fall down you laughing it's you
don't fart you put in your butt like all
you invented the [__] no fart plug
you can't now you get all sorts of butt
plugs um but did you know Ben Franklin
like loved to [__] live it up
he loved to [__] hookers of course he
did when I heard that I went like this
of course he did dude
of course Ben Franklin loved to get
[__] love to barber of course Ben
Franklin
two Berber when he went bracket kick
kack kack of course he did and you know
when he got [__] he would go oh you
know it after the sandwich I'll get it
you know I'd love to sit in my chair get
a [__] here for sure after the
sandwich I'd love to sit in my [__]
chair and just take a relaxing sit I'd
love to take a sit and they would be so
disrespectful but it wasn't
disrespectful back then excuse me could
you fetch me a milky [__] you know and
she would come by with her [__] tits
all out and [__] and he like I'm going
to sit in my [__] chair and while I
finish this you know what I finished
this bread sandwich like he would just
be this cheese bread sandwich would you
mind if I just unloaded my sack into
your trachea and she were like sure
because I an event and he'd sit there
and then she'd do it and then he'd have
his [__] eat his sandwich on his
belly while he was getting just sucked
off and he would be like oh oh that's
how he would bust and then she'd leave
and he would like invent a [__] visor
you know this keeps your hat your head
cool but still the Sun out of your eyes
MA now let me take you know I would love
to get sucked by a milky [__] let me
undress give me 35 minutes because I'm
wearing too many things you see what
they wore dude they they have guys in
Philly like in the area where all the
museums are they have guys still dressed
like that like for fun and I'm just like
bro it's summer you know why do you have
seven pair of pants on in two boots and
a fake like like just the next
pouch and below we asked [__] pants
it's 85 degrees
you don't need to do that who you doing
this for the kids they don't really give
a [__] you can just give them a lollipop
and they'd be much happier he preferred
older women as lovers did you know that
and this is why I have an excerpt from
what the [__] it is this is unbelievable
that he wrote this [__] and it was
public because if you wrote something
like this you're cancelled right now the
faced he would just write [__] Benjamin
Franklin didn't give a [__] he would
just write [__] this was a letter he
wrote to some people you could just like
be like when you were in the 70s you
just write a letter and then just send
it to a bunch of people and that counted
as a book this is what it says the face
first grows lank and wrinkled then the
neck then the breast in arms the lower
parts continuing to the last as plump as
ever
so that covering all above with a basket
and regarding only what is below the
girdle it is simply impossible of two
women to know and old from a young one
and as in the dark all cats are gray the
pleasure of corporal enjoyment with an
old woman is at least equal and
frequently superior every nak being by
practice capable of improvement
cancelled dude this is the part that is
the [__] disrespectful dude this is
the part and as in the dark all cats are
gray doesn't matter and then this part
so that covering all above meaning above
the waist with a basket basically he's
the 2 Live Crew of his [__]
generation being like yeah put a paper
bag over her face if she's ugly and
[__] empty your sack in er hey Ben
Franklin
dude he's kid Ben Franklin's cancelled
bro I know he discovered electricity and
a man invented the bifocals you know why
he invented the I don't know why event
the bifocals didn't matter what [__]
rumps we're looking like all cats are
gray when you dim the lights that's just
to go that's just to show you dude it's
a sign of the times and the times are
always at changing and also the leaders
are always the most [__] insane
people Donald Trump Kanye West whoever
the [__] you want to say they're they're
always the most insane when Donald Trump
said yeah it was nice [__] Iran
didn't shoot didn't [__] murderer 130
people in cold blood house nice to them
hey you're crazy and that's what that's
who the leaders are in the dark all cats
are gray talking about women yeah say
sexist hey put it off dude let me write
a letter to a bunch of people encounter
has a book hey dude just put a bag over
her face if she's old and then [__] her
this guy was a leader wow dude yeah talk
about dadbod that guy had a grand dad
bod so insane dude crazy how times have
changed right okay I guess you know I'm
so stuffed up and it's all good dude I
don't give a [__] you know I'm not
letting this [__] take me down
lion has dadbod [__] bro you
know this app cameo that where you can
like be on cameo and you can record
personal messages for people who are
fans of yours I got on cameo anytime
there's a new app I get on it because I
feel like I should be on the new [__]
never know what's gonna become the next
Instagram whatever and I also like doing
social media and I never know if I'm
gonna like it until I already use it for
a bunch so I got the app cameo and these
[__] dude I got cameo and I put
it on for $1000 because I saw the people
were doing them for like 50 bucks a Duda
here's the deal okay I'm not I'm not
recording personal messages for people
for like [__] 30 dollars a pop did
I'm not going either
hey Jason heard it was your birthday
yeah Chris D'Elia here live it up no
dent and send it to him like and then
you get that for [__] 30 it's not
worth it to me okay be a fan cool not
recording personal messages all day to
make [__] $700 you know what I'm
saying this is not my bag also so I put
it up I was like what's the most I could
charge a thousand bucks no way I'm doing
it for less than a thousand bucks no
[__] way so couldn't do it for more
cos kemiya wouldn't let you you think I
wouldn't do it for 50 grand you're out
of your [__] mind dude I want to be
the most expensive guy in cameo don't
give a [__] okay I I so I did it got a
few requests actually got like seven
requests for a cameo person on my bra
make seven grand off this [__] so all of
a sudden I'm like all right maybe I'll
do it even though I don't want it did
one okay two things happen felt cheapest
[__] cuz I was like yeah you can't what
am I gonna do like 90 of these and
they're gonna all over the internet like
hey [__] Alyssa hope your bar mitzvah
was good bar mitts what do you call him
for chicks butt mitts get pick one you
know pick your [__] maybe I hope your
Mitzvah was good I'm calling my mitzvahs
from now on
hope hope your Mitzvah was good and then
and then that's it and I'm not gonna do
a Mona do seven of these No so then I
was like all right I might not do it
again then I found out cameo takes 25%
bro oh look cameo respect your hustle
but also you you want to take that much
money from me so I didn't do another one
okay not doing another one unless I can
charge out the [__] anus you
understand me dude I'm not doing it dude
it's too you got to draw the line
somewhere
I'm not what hey new app new app give
your phone number to fans for 50 bucks
they can call you whatever they want no
[__] you out of your mind dude so you
know so they took [__] 25% of the
[__] and on my RF so I'm never doing it
again dude I swear to god they the
people on cameo they email me they text
me they [__] do all the shit's
they're like hey you got booked again I
don't give a [__] okay I respect your
hustle all good do what you got to do
because I get it but no dude I'm not
doing it all right I'll make money other
ways so they got me on their goddamn
website like you can get a cameo for me
you can't all right I didn't know that
they put me on the [__] website
either I didn't know that [__] bro if
you could put me on the [__] if I can
charge 50k for a shout-out so I can
but bro you're gonna take [__] now
how much you're gonna take from that 50k
you're gonna take 12 grand from that I
understand but bro give me at least
[__] 38 of that [__] look around on
my bio I ain't doing this [__] for less
than one care I'd make it more but cameo
doesn't allow me to do it no face crime
in this like literally when they were
younger their dad would beat the [__]
out of them when they laughed when they
laughed that stuff that wasn't
technically funny according to the dad
no face crime in that video don't push
me cause I'm close to the edge and if
they make one move with their face haha
face crime and then so they laugh haha
but my point is look at look at these
people charging this [__] for a look at
this look at this
Chuck Liddell what's he charged for this
thing Skippy tell 125 bucks for a
shout-out okay fine now look that guy I
don't know if he's got money in like
real estate or some [__] his fighting
career is probably you know he's
probably not fighting too much anymore I
get it he's I'm sure he's made millions
of dollars I think scroll up Lance Bass
boy Brett Farr Brett Farr 500 bucks why
would the [__] is Brett Farve doing this
for these guys Skechers deal or some
[__] uh you know these influencers I get
Brittany Furlan that dr. Drew $198 the
[__] is this [__] I love dr. Drew the
[__] is he do 100 90
also and make it 200 what are you a
[__] what do you a pair of speakers
look at it Pauly Shore a hundred fifty
poly fine Bryan Callen a hundred dollars
the [__] are you doing the [__] are you
doing God makes a million dollars on his
goddamn podcast the [__] is he need $100
to say hey Craig hope you're having a
good [__] 25th birthday Joey Fatone
look at this [__]
Kevin O'Leary the [__] billionaire on
shark tank for 999 999 dollars what the
[__] is he doing bro don't you own earth
what is wrong with these [__]
what the [__] is wrong with everybody on
cameo for real honestly look at this
leave this loo this look at this [__] go
up look at somebody's my [__]
[__] look at this [__] Ryan
Cabrera $40 [__] go up a little more
who's this
Ruth Johnny Damon Andra it's got a
[__] contract from like 3000 million
in [__] 2009 and he's gay
hey what's up Johnny Damon here used to
play for the [__] Botox just want to
wish you a happy Anniversary to you and
your wife go ahead slugger for $114 guys
gonna make seventy five dollars off this
[__] cuz cameo takes his [__] [__]
[Music]
unbelievable to get neo dude a hundred
neo seriously makes for real fifty
million dollars just stepping into
Europe he just steps onto European land
and makes 50 million dollars okay this
guy's charging 125 dollars for a person
you know what how about this no no
[__] now I'm not only I'm not on
cameo anymore for that I'm
I in a [__] personalized message to
Neil from Neil that's what I'm [__]
doing right now after this podcast I am
purchasing a [__] personalized
message from Neil I'm gonna give him 125
dollars because I want him to be like yo
what's up Chris D'Elia hey how you doing
this Neil even though this dude makes 50
million dollars as soon as the [__]
Learjet door opens in [__] Sweden as
soon as that [__] opens a guy shows up
with a briefcase thing goes here's 50
mil cash and neo [__] moon walks
backwards into the [__] plane and
goes badly we need to perform I'm gonna
buy a [__] shoutout from Neil on
cameo straight up so hopefully we'll
have it by next week why am I not doing
this but why am I not buying all these
by the way I'm buying all these
[__] x' why have I not thought
of this it's unbelievable I haven't
thought of this speaking of making
[__] money hey guys look guys are
terrible at taking care of their health
whether it's a knee injury bad back or
something worse guys are usually more
comfortable rubbing some dirt on it then
seeing a doctor I'm guilty of it myself
the same is true for erectile
dysfunction
studies show 70% of guys who experience
erectile dysfunction don't get treated
for it thankfully Roman created an easy
way to get checked out by a doctor and
get treated for IDI online having
trouble going breka quook quook quook
check out Roman Roman is a one-stop shop
where you can chat with a licensed u.s.
physician who can treat Edie and if safe
and appropriate ship medication right to
your door uh with Roman there are no
waiting rooms
no awkward face-to-face conversations no
uncomfortable trips to the pharmacy you
can handle everything discreetly online
all I have to do is visit get Roman
Comstock Congrats completed online visit
chat with the doctor and if the doctor
doctor decides it would be safe
inappropriate then though ship genuine
medication right to your door in this
creet unmarked packaging so you don't
have to be embarrassed if that were to
embarrass you for a free online visit go
to get Roman dot-com / Congrats that's
get Roman comm / congrats for a free
online visit get Roman comm / Congrats
no bull that's no bull it's time to
demand more from your workout gear the
way you demand more from yourself right
no bull is a footwear apparel and
accessory brand from people who train
hard and don't believe in excuses
like me no bull is on a mission to
create products built for people who
train hard day after day no bull doesn't
believe in excuses or BS and that's why
you won't find any in their Footwear
apparel or accessories wear and Terra is
welcome no Bull has you covered
don't let the simple design fool you no
Bulls gear is built to perform launched
in 2015 Noble has become a key disruptor
in the fitness industry the philosophy
is don't put anything on a product that
doesn't do anything take everything off
that you don't need and be honest about
what the product does right for simple
durable and functional training gear
visit noble project comm / Congrats
training gear for people who work hard
and don't believe in excuses
visit noble project comm / Congrats and
get your gear today that's n OB u ll p
ro je CT comm / congrats congratulations
is brought to you by cash app which is
an app which is like a dream your phone
has that's what they paid me to say my
babies so that's what we're saying
ah but yeah dude you know what I'm
talking about
la la palma da ha
ib doesn't rhyme so basic due to mace
you know mace quit became a pastor then
tried to get back in the rap game that's
not gonna work
hey mace hello this is earth oh yeah
wait hello I have more to say doesn't
matter
hey mace this is Earth you don't get to
quit become a pastor for 10 years and
then come back and all of a sudden I'm
pissed that this [__] arm is just
taking it off this [__] thing's got
Edie for [__] sake dude can't wait to
get a [__] cameo from me oh dude how
much gonna get one from Sean Astin for
[__] $250 dude somebody tweeted were
like oh the only thing funny about
crystally is that he thinks he's worth
$1000 Kinnaman dude shut the [__] up
this [__] is priceless bro unless you
want to pay 50k but that's what it is
that's what it is cool
when I was dude I was thinking about
this when I was a kid I the earliest
memory you have do you remember the
earliest memory you have it's like it's
like hard to remember beyond before like
three you know I remember when my
brother was delivered they say that like
a baby's a pizza but I remember when my
brother was born and he came home and he
was in the car
and I asked my mom because I was sitting
next to him and he was in the car seat
and I was like why does he have wrinkly
hands
most of what his fingers all wrinkly and
I was like oh that happens to babies
because they're you know that's just
their skin isn't ready yet or some [__]
I remember that then also remember that
day when my brother got home my grandpa
got me a he-man toy and when they gave
me the he-man toys and they said all
Christians Michael I said yeah but he
just got me that because he's here and I
pointed to my brother this is smart as a
three and a half year old because
they're trying to make him feel good and
also worth something even though my
brother was in the world now and he was
still and he's still my thunder and it's
all good but that day he stole my
thunder because he was born okay but I
also remember a time one of the other
earliest memories I ever had was when I
was in my bedroom as a young young kid
young young boy there were I had crayons
in this yellow box I forget what the
other box was called but you would
unlatch the box open it up and they were
open and I took the Kranz out and I
started drawing on the wall and my
parents came in later and they were like
oh my god what the [__] did you do you
drew all over the wall and I remember
having the feeling thinking what you
can't draw you can't color on the wall I
remember feeling like I didn't mean to
do anything wrong dude how crazy is that
that I remember a time learning about
how and like I didn't know it was bad to
color on the wall and that was when I
learned it was bad to deface stuff
that's [__] I felt good that I
remembered that I remember thinking like
oh my god I didn't mean to do something
bad
why is this [__] thing not work okay
well this is breaking but we'll fix it
one fire literally just goes up oh but
yeah remember that what's your earliest
memory tweet me but you know what I
don't give a [__] but still you should
think about it for yourself cuz you know
if it's when you were like 12 you got
[__] huge problems you're trying to
are going to hide something
this is another thought I had that I
never [__] thought about but like we
have balls and a dick
you know guys and like think about how
uncomfortable that is for real like you
don't think about how comfortable is
because just how you are but think about
if you just balls and dicks didn't exist
and then all the sudden we just got
balls and dicks oh we would never not
think about it every second of the day
we'd be like oh [__] they'd be like
you're you you want to go grab a soda
out of the fridge you be like all right
this I got this balls and dick I don't
know man
III just wanna be careful you know can
we post mates it it'd be like it but not
write to your chair be like alright I'll
go get a [__] I'll tell you what I'm
hungry I'll get up because I gotta get
food and the drink that's crazy that we
have balls and dick that's insane that
we just have this [__] target in the
middle of our bodies that can be lightly
brushed up against and ruin our [__]
hour that's insane and we just have them
girl so I have them bro if a girl gets
kicked in the in the you know in the I
don't like to say like this but if a
girl gets kicked on the [__] then she
gets [__] she's like ow but it hurts
like she gets punched in the arm if you
get kicked in the balls it hurts like
you get kicked in your nucleus dude you
didn't kick them you nucleus
that [__] is probably would hurt as much
the prior it's more than if someone were
to reach inside and squeeze your brain
and we just have them on us that's
[__] Jesus Christ should have made
some [__] protective gear you know we
had to do it manually as humans we had
to make a jockstrap bro Jesus
get on it we got balls on the outside
come on bro make a [__] football
helmet you know give us football helmets
over our balls and we could have
different teams and [__] but like all
you got all you got the Eagles I would
I'll get the Viking I would like to be
the Vikings I would like to have purple
ones a purple one you know anyway that's
all I'm saying is you don't
realize how [__] dainty balls are uh
until you think about what if we just
got them you know and that's probably
the most important thing I possibly said
on this whole podcast today or maybe
even ever remember that episode 126 I
think so yeah watch out for your balls
dude girls don't get it - well time I
got hitting my balls I was playing
t-ball
I was playing second base and the and
the the dude the kid hit the ball off
the tee ball and I just went to go catch
it and I miss it hit my balls no so
embarrassing and the coaches came up and
they were like oh no well where did it
hit you and I said my stomach and they
said Oh Hugh and I realized that they
said Hugh because it wasn't my balls but
it was my ball but I was too embarrassed
so I could have done some real damage
luckily doesn't matter I can still go
break her kakak and ball yelling I get
still burber with the best of them I can
still [__] realize cats are in the
darkest of times cats are gray and the
dimmest of light cats are gray I can
still put a basket over the top half of
a woman and realize cats are gray
Benjamin Franklin perv
you know what Benjamin Franklin invaded
invented the the [__] bifocals you've
discovered electricity and also invented
the perv so that's cool
invented hooking so that's what's up
what let's go to let's do some what do
you call them
miss connections from la la miss
connections la miss connections is that
it that's all you said man how about
kawaii how about how he made a career
off of a laughs that's amazing I mean
he's great but that do popped when he
laughed boringly okay here we go la you
gave me a hand job on a flight from JFK
to LAX two nights ago Wow
it's always so crazy how these people
don't exchange numbers to me I'm a guy
you're a girl if this is you I don't
think I need to be too specific unless
you do this often lol anyway I can't
stop thinking about this I don't know
why we didn't exchange info well neither
do I you [__] weirdo because she made
you spurt you know what I mean hey if
someone makes you spurt get their number
how about that do it what are you a
[__] neanderthal do not contact me
will not solicit services or offers I
highly doubt that I bet somebody would
probably be like well I'll do it and be
like okay do it imagine being on a
flight I've never done anything on a
flight like that never mile-high club
people talk about that I'm like what oh
dude you want to go into the bathroom
together and [__] 333 thousand miles in
the air feet in the air sorry thirty
thousand feet in air are you are you out
of your mind
busting is for the ground that's it save
your busting for concrete here's another
one
glory hole open North Hollywood all one
word by the way I guess I got I don't
have time for spaces I mean who you
foolin we can read it
glory hole open North Hollywood open now
wow this is an ad for a glory hole Jesus
Christ does this cost money glory hole
open now [__] cameo on cameo glory
hole is open occasionally servicing
anyone who is curious or wants anonymous
set up private apartment parking in
front door unlock walk in drop pants and
insert through gh hey man just write it
out at this point okay I think there's
got enough time bring your own porn huh
as if that's not [__] sexy enough
bring your own porn have towels and hand
sanitizer for easy clean
yeah but oh I know what it's for bust
and go service bus didn't go discreet
here inquire within
open to questions North Hollywood area
open around 10 a.m. and on Imagine
[__] getting your dick sucked through
a hole before lunch yeah I'll meet you
at a L pond I meet you at lip pain or
whatever the [__] that place is yeah
I'll meet you at [__] let pain but
we're you know twelve are cool yes in
North Hollywood yeah I'll meet you there
I'll meet you at [__] Rusty's pizza
over in Burbank send picks a number for
faster service and replies open now do
not contact me with some solicited
services offers the whole thing is
[__] unsolicited services or officer
dude got so many Edwards for no reason
alright man well if you want a glory
hole go hit up this [__] what the
[__] oh pie licking and more looking to
eat some one out as long as they are
clean okay no background check be
careful also don't do it I'll make sure
you come multiple times yeah he's got an
ego
I'm 100 percent real I have snapchat if
you want to get to know me hahaha please
send a pic along with email thanks do
not solicit do not kind of move with
unsolicited services or offers you know
it's like I love when guys are like I'll
make sure you come I love when guys are
like dude I'm good in bed
that's so funny to me to have a guy be
like to think that a guy's like that is
like hell yeah all night long here we go
and then as soon as he does he's just
like oh okay well sorry want to listen
to some music
I mean so many n words in that song
never realized it you know around so
bigger alright so that's it you know
puff was 12 when they recorded that song
um all right my babies did we had a good
episode that was really fun
we've got to get this [__] cameo
going from neo hopefully he'll do it
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market download
the Chris D'Elia app where you can watch
me live before anyone else does on the
podcast on the podcast on
congratulations I support the show by
buying merch at store crystal Viacom or
just go to Christy let Delia come and
find and click through the [__] if
you're not a [__] ignoramus you'll be
able to figure it out get gift cards to
if you know someone's a fan subscribe to
the YouTube channel please and rate and
review the show that really helps us on
iTunes [__] and on the charts and all
that video episodes go up a day after
the audio podcast so thank you very much
and check me out in Hoover a Memphis
Chattanooga and Knoxville this week
still tickets left on some of those
venues in Atlantic City and Tarrytown
New York thank you very much Terry I'm
going there I guess and that's it that's
what's up thank you very much
you guys are great and I still got some
big news coming haven't be able to
[__] report it yet but I will have a
good one
[Music]